will i think we got you here hey guys
let's just start first with uh the kind
of price structure uh you went ahead and
you've got this uh uh this tweet that or
i'm sorry uh this uh chart that shows
kind of price movement over the last
couple of months what are you seeing
here right so if you remember from last
week what we talked about was we were
expecting volatility i kind of said i
had no real strong opinion about where
price was headed in the short term uh
but you know i was expecting some
volatility and that's when we were
right smack dab in the middle of these
the two bollinger bands um and so the
squeeze is highlighted by that yellow
shaded area and i'm using the wick high
time frame indicator to identify that
what we talked about last week was that
for the past three volatility squeezes
we've had we've initially gone in one
direction to grab liquidity from the
breakout traders and then gone in the
opposite direction and so once again
this this actually happened
again on this on this fourth time on on
wednesday uh we broke out above the
bollinger band looked like we were
having to squeeze to the upside grabbed
liquidity and then reversed um and so
yeah i mean
i'm not saying that i necessarily like
called this but it's just like we were
prepared for this and and what you know
what we talked about last week was like
we were in the middle of the bands but
to to kind of check your you know check
your bias in terms of like
you know
if it did look like it was breaking to
the upside but you know if we if you had
been paying attention to what we
mentioned in the newsletter last week
then you wouldn't have you know just
been
you know fully bullish like you would
you would have been aware that there's
the potential that we would have this
reversal which we end up doing so now
we've had four of those in a row where
we've broken out grab liquidity and
reverse
as far as like price structure um these
are just levels that i've i've had in
here for like weeks now um you know i
think as long as we're above this kind
of green this green zone which was that
point of breakdown from earlier this
year um i remain bullish i mean i'm not
saying that this will happen but i think
we could correct as low as like 51 to
53k and still have uh still maintain
like bullish market structure i think if
that happened you would see some some
you know sideways consolidation but i
think as long as we were maintaining
above that level just from like a pure
price structure standpoint um you know
i'm not like macro bearish got it okay
and then you have this piece here where
essentially once we saw that uh break
all the way up to 69 000 which is of
course like bitcoin hitting 69 thousand
dollars is uh is almost like the mean
you bet we didn't hit 69 420 that would
have been even better dude the memes
write themselves like of course 69 000
is the bitcoin all-time high uh we got a
large influx of open interest so what
are you seeing here with this futures
open interest perpetual on the exchanges
right so as we broke all-time highs you
just saw a real big influx of open
interest basically people trying to buy
that breakout as we mentioned a second
ago
especially on binance you saw a real
high
increase in
open interest particularly um the coin
margin contracts or crypto margin
contracts so we've talked about this
before
when you're margining a futures contract
with crypto versus stable coins or usd
um you have more convexity to the
downside which just is a fancy term for
saying you know as the trade goes
against you you're long you're basically
longing your longs right like you're
longing bitcoin with bitcoin um let's
say you know the trade starts to go
against you well not only is your p l
going down your profit and loss going
down or the you know the
profit of the trade is going down but
your collateral or how collateralized
you are is decreasing in tandem with
that um and so that can create these
these washouts and so yeah we had a
large uh increase in in
open interest as well as um funding was
rising a bit
and then you pair that with you know we
had like the cpi data as well as
evergrand news and then we also had a
couple major exchanges that went down
including ftx which from my
understanding that's like the first time
ftx has gone down ver during any kind of
like significant uh market move usually
ftx has always been the one exchange
that hasn't gone down um and so i mean i
don't think you can really like pinpoint
price action at least one specific thing
but like those factors kind of uh you
know gave the perfect recipe for a flesh
out
got it now sopra this is the entity
adjusted sopra uh which i feel like you
and i sopra we're uh we're on a journey
together here but what's going on with
sopra
all right so sober is our spin output
profit ratio so we're looking at um when
a coin was last moved and and when it's
being moved so okay let me say this
we're looking at all the coins that are
trading on a given day so you know
it's you the coins that are being spent
today you're looking at the profit and
loss that those coins that are being
spent today hold so if a coin was you
know bought at
50k it's now being moved at 60k well
that coins realizing ten thousand
dollars of profit if a coin was bought
you know at the pico top at 69k
and then now it's sold down here at 63k
well it's realizing six thousand dollars
losses so you're only looking at the
coins that are being spent on on each
given trading day and then you run the
ratio between the profit and loss and
you get sober which is spent i'll put
profit ratio
one is kind of that threshold where you
know if you divide one by one it's
neutral right so if the profit and loss
is balancing each other out then you're
at one above that the market's trading
in a state of profit below it's trading
in a net state of loss
and so what you want to see in bearish
trend or well in bullish trends is
coming back down and bouncing off that
one threshold on any kind of major
correction and bearish trends what
you're looking for is a failed retest
from the underside of one
and so what you'll see is
uh you can't see this on the chart but
we bounced off uh one in in september of
last year we had a continued uptrend in
the ratio
as you can see we had i didn't i didn't
label this actually but you can see this
bearish divergence where the oscillator
was making lower highs as price was
making higher highs
so that was kind of an early warning
sign we had this reversal broke down
below one
and that's what i have marked as that
bearish break so at that point you know
you can have a bearish bias but you
don't quite have absolute confirmation
yet um coming back down you know
that that initial failed break above
that range we were in over summer we had
that failed retest from the underside of
one and that was confirmation that we
were in uh kind of a broader bullish
trend um got a second uh confirmation of
you know the underside test of one and
then very shortly after we actually got
a bullish break above one um and so from
there then you you know you have bullish
bias generally towards the market but we
are once again waiting for that
confirmation uh we came back down and
retested 40k
about a month ago at the end of
september and that's when we got that
bullish confirmation now we're kind of
hovering uh you know a bit above one um
you know i would love to come down and
retest um you know on some kind of
correction and hit that one threshold
but when you go back to last year i mean
after we had that retest after september
we had like a 25 correction right before
the major
phase of the bull run at the end of last
year
and we never came back down and retested
one again we just continued an uptrend
so
what i'm looking for is
if we have a price correction to come
back down and re-test one in general
though i'm expecting this probably just
to trend higher and you know as we get
further into the bull run i would be
looking for another bearish divergence
as as you can see we had on the
left-hand side of the chart um you know
when we were in like april uh march
april kind of time frame
when we look at this utxo realized price
distribution uh you've got it squared
off and you said 18.36 of the supply why
are you calling that out and explain
what this chart's showing us
sure so this is realized price
distribution so we talk about realized
price which is uh the capitalization of
bitcoin based off the last time coins
are moved so you know with this in mind
what this is showing is
if a coin is last moved at 1 000 no it's
in the it's in the 1 000 uh bar volume
if it's then moved once again at 20k
well now it's pulled out of the 1k bar
and moved into the 20k bar so that's
where the realized aspect is coming from
you're so you're essentially looking at
where uh where each denominated at each
denominated uh price level how much of
supply has last moved there
and so as you can see
above 50 i forget the exact number
because it changes as supply increases
of what exactly the price level is that
the 1 trillion dollar market cap
threshold is but it's above 53k so i
just cut it off at 54k
but roughly 18.3 percent 18.36
of bitcoin's money supply has moved
above that one trillion dollar uh
threshold and so to me that's showing
that there's confirmation from the
market uh well from marked participants
that this you know asset class is here
to stay um and that you know bitcoin is
is establishing itself as like a as a
maturing macro asset i think you know
that that 1 trillion
that 1 trillion threshold is kind of a
line in the sand as you can see that's
kind of where this cluster that we're
currently in starts
got it and when you look at this price
distribution uh that cluster what are
you looking to see happen over like say
the remainder of the bull market like
what is your expectation there
um i mean the way i just see it is like
by definition you're showing where a lot
of mark participants or capital inflows
have come in so ideally like these zones
of volume are kind of uh support or
resistance levels because they're
they're levels where market participants
have interacted heavily with so if
you're coming up from the underside to a
large you know cluster of uh you know
realized price distribution and saying
you're probably going to face some
resistance some people that are taking
profits
and then conversely if you know for
correcting then you know i look for some
of these uh some of these zones as like
you know support levels uh on on the you
know on a move down so uh that's kind of
the way i see it um but yeah i mean this
will definitely change over time because
you know you'll have coins that are um
you know in whatever 40 50 you know in
those in those price levels that are
gonna move once we go higher so you know
this is it's just just something to to
watch in terms of like identifying where
a lot of this investor behavior is going
on
got it and so when we look at this uh
new chart that you have the uh i
appreciate in the newsletter that you uh
published this morning you said next we
take a look at a new variant of illiquid
supply that i created yesterday like you
are moving so fast to create some of
this stuff and continue to analyze it
what are you showing here in this new
illiquid supply shock kind of this new
variation of it
sure so usually we look at a liquid
supply shock ratio which i created with
willy woo over the summer um what that
basically is doing is it's comparing the
liquid guys which are essentially the
strong hands so they take in um and
don't spend at least 75 percent of those
of the coins they take in so for every
four coins they take in they hold at
least three the liquid guys take in and
spend 50 50 and then the highly liquid
guys spend over 75 percent of the coins
they take in so for every four coins
they take and they only hold one
and so you run the ratio of the liquid
aka the strong hands to the weak hands
which are the highly and and
highly liquid and liquid guys and that's
what the liquid supply shock ratio is
but i just was tinkering around with it
and like took it a step further by
applying an rsi to it
and you can apply different time frames
i just thought this one was the clearest
the two month or 60 day version of it
you could look at it like the 30 day
version or whatever um but what i'm what
i'm just trying to point out here is
similar to uh what we talked about in
soper with the bearish divergence and
also you'll see in the chart after this
another bearish divergence to non-chain
what you're looking for here is seeing
that
the rsi which is essentially measuring
the momentum so in this case you're
looking at the momentum of a liquid
supply shock so you're looking at the
momentum of the supply dynamics right so
you know if if you have a bearish
divergence which is when the oscillator
is making lower highs then showing the
the amount of supply or the strength of
the supply shock is getting weaker
meanwhile you know price is making
higher highs so you can see that happen
in 2017 um once we broke that down trend
in 2019 at the bottom of 2019 that kind
of marked the bottom of the bear market
we had a continued uptrend in the ratio
and then as you can see kind of at like
the the beginning of this year actually
you could you could say it started as we
broke all-time highs in december at the
end of last year we began this this
bearish divergence between the
oscillator
and price once we broke below that the
green line i have which is just which is
you know showing the uptrend in the
metric once we broke below that uh then
we had that may capitulation event so
showing that the trend of supply getting
locked up uh broke um and then since
then we've we've broken back above that
downtrend uh which is like a you know a
bullish break above very similar to what
we just talked about it you know at the
beginning of 2019 when we broke that
down trend so uh you know we're in we're
in bullish territory now we broke that
at the end of september um after we
retested 40k
and so you know what i'm looking for
moving forward and like
i posted this yesterday and like
you know maybe maybe it's a big
miscommunication on my end but um you
know it seems like some people kind of
miss nuance in the sense of like
i wasn't saying that this this is
bearish i'm just saying like what i'm
looking for moving forward so like you
know we've we've been um you know
i kind of got caught off guard by the
move in may and then over summer i
really kind of grinded out my
understanding of all this stuff because
you know i i kind of you know i was kind
of pissed that you know i missed the
whole move and then i really got like
dove deep and on chain created a lot of
these new metrics and like really took
it seriously uh and so now you know with
that being with that in mind like i'm
looking for moving forward you know what
are some of them trying to stay
objective as possible and look forward
you know what are the things moving
forward that we we can identify that are
showing that the market's starting to
get overheated or when we should start
becoming cautious and with this specific
metric what i'm looking for is another
bearish divergence as we had in 2017
and also earlier this year so
you know we're in bullish territory for
the metric now um and as you can see you
know it takes a couple touches of in you
know on that on that downtrend once we
begin the bearish divergence before it
actually plays out but you know after we
have two three touches per se you know
i'll you know probably start to become
pretty cautious especially paired with
um some other metrics but that's you
know that's what i'm looking for
specifically with this metric moving
forward
got it and then checkmate has this
market realized gradient uh i'm
unfamiliar with this so how do you
describe this you put a little bit in
the newsletter in terms of the actual uh
language that's used to uh to describe
it but like
how do you think about this in a way
that people can use it
yeah so this is a great metric uh
created by czech maiden um checkmate was
uh checkmate's been doing on-chain since
like 2018 and checkmate was actually
bearish um earlier this year mostly
because of this metric
and so what essentially you're looking
at here is
the rate of change between realized cap
and price and so we've talked about
realized cap i'm not going to explain it
because i feel like we talked about it
every time i talked about two minutes
ago but um you're looking at the rate of
change so the amount of new capital
inflows relative to the speculative bid
on price um and so you know as long as
as long as realize cap is increasing
along with the rate of change of price
um then you know it's fine we're an
uptrend and that's that's what you're
seeing right now um but earlier this
year you had uh the rate of change of
realize price was going down as price
was increasing so you had this bearish
divergence between um the the realized
gradient and price um and so that's
that's what i'm looking for moving
forward as we get you know
higher over the coming months which i'm
expecting
um you know i'm looking for this
oscillator to start making these these
lower highs um you know essentially
you're just looking at like the the
delta which just means like the
difference between the rate of change of
of realized cap or new capital inflows
and the speculative bid that market
participants are bidding up the market
got it and then when you start to look
at uh this on-chain cost basis i think
we talked about this uh maybe last week
but there there's definitely been kind
of a reversal of the previous trend so
describe this one
yeah so dylan had this good idea about a
month ago or so to compare the
short-term holder and long-term holder
realized price um and if you can't tell
like realize price is one of the most
important metrics in on in on chain
analysis to understand
um but specifically by comparing the
short term and long term holder realized
price you can get some interesting
signals so another way to think of
realized price is um a you can think of
it as uh for someone who's like a more
technical trader a vwop which is a
volume weighted average price um or you
could just think of it as the cost basis
of investors
and so
by looking at the short and long term
holders but what you see is that when
short-term holder cost basis goes below
the long-term holder cost basis or
realized price that's generally a good
time to to start buying heavily
and that's highlighted by that you know
you'll see that that green line at the
bottom
what that's basically showing is like
all the the short term holder were the
speculators um you know that were that
were you know
likely in the in the previous bull run
or or they had kind of bought on the way
down you know thinking that it was just
like a another by the dip opportunity or
whatever
they kind of capitulate you know when
the market seems like it's never going
to stop going down right because i mean
you know newbies usually buy when they
think the market isn't going to ever
stop going up and they sell when they
think the market isn't going to stop
going down which is the complete
opposite of what you should be doing but
nonetheless um you know this is just
showing that you know there's the
short-term guys completely leave during
the bear market and we that's also
reflected by like short-term holder
supply and like hotter waves
but they leave in the bear market and
then conversely um we can use this to
kind of identify when the market's
getting overheated in the bull market uh
when short-term holder realized price
kind of way you know overshoots uh
long-term hold at realized price so just
showing that you know the the short-term
guys are dominating
the market and they're basically you
know buying the buying uh the long-term
holders guys bags and there's a lot of
exuberance and new market entrance um in
the market so
got it and then we got a red print on
the long term holder net position change
um
is this bullish or bearish i guess is my
first question and then like why do you
see uh why do you think we're seeing
this like can you explain like what's
driving it
yeah um yeah i posted this one this
morning and um
there's definitely some confusion as to
like what this exactly means
um but what we're looking at here is the
30-day change of long-term holder supply
so we're looking at for example you know
what was long-term holder supply on
october 12th and then we're comparing it
to today then we take the net change
between the two
and so what we've talked about for the
for the past two well let's back it up
over summer we started this
re-accumulation phase and we saw that
the long-term guys were starting to lock
up supply via liquid supply and also
just the long-term holder supply metric
via glass node
and so what we talked about is that
we're looking to reach this peak hotter
level which we reached i mean honestly
faster than uh i thought we would we we
reached an all-time high in the
long-term holder supply shock ratio and
since then we started to see old coins
being spent and this is something that
we've talked about you know
this this is natural bull market
behavior what you see in these natural
dynamics between market participants is
that the long-term guys buy weakness
they set the floor in the bear market
and then once the kind of reflexivity of
a full-blown bitcoin bull market or
momentum of a full-blown bitcoin uh bull
market takes off then you have the
short-term guys or new market entrants
that come in and buy the long-term the
long-term guys bags the whole way up
um and so you know
we peeked out well like i said we peeked
out reach an all-time high in the spy
shock ratio um now we're starting to see
those those long-term holders distribute
uh we can see this via long-term holder
supply long-term holder net position
change um
you know average spin output life span
spent volume age bands coin dates
destroyed dormancy um all these
different metrics uh that are just
showing that you're starting to see
these long-term guys um sell off and
that's not that doesn't mean that the
bull market is over that's just like i
said natural bull market dynamics um and
as you can see when when the long-term
guys actually initiated uh or started to
sell uh previously uh you know that was
that actually kind of coincidentally at
the end of october of last year you know
that was at the very beginning of the
bull run and and you know we always talk
about how
these guys don't perfectly time the tops
and bottoms like they don't perfectly
buy the pico bottom of of the bear
market and they don't perfectly time the
the pico top of of uh the bulls they
kind of you know scale into the bear and
scale out in the bowl um and so you're
just starting to see them scale out and
that you know that
this is this is a bullish chart over the
coming months um but you know once once
we once we start to see real heavy
selling like as you can see like in
january the
beginning of this year um then you know
you can start
start to become cautious and then when
we flip green that's actually generally
kind of a a bearish signal because
that's showing that the long-term guys
you know have started buying back again
and that's like naturally what what uh
bear market behavior
looks like so
you know this isn't something to be like
entirely concerned about at all it's
just like you know just keep an eye on
this over the next couple you know next
couple months and this is kind of the
start of the end but that you know it
doesn't mean to say that we don't have a
long way to go because these guys don't
you know they've just started scaling
out and they definitely don't perfectly
time the top so yeah i i tend to think
that that's right based on the the data
that we have from previous uh kind of
upward movements uh we've got supply
shock ratios what uh what what are you
seeing here same kind of reversal right
there at the bottom
right yeah i mean this is just another
visual to show the same thing um so this
is like the complete zoomed out version
though so green is long-term holder
supply
and purple or fuchsia whatever you want
to call that color that's the short term
holder supply and so you i'm just
threw this in there to show that dynamic
um you know you see in 2013 uh the
long-term guys were buying up until the
main phase of that that first leg up
they scaled out during that and then
they rebought during that uh kind of
mini bear phase between the two 2013
double pumps and then they sold again um
into that rally while the short term
guys bought their bags the whole way up
long-term guys started scaling in
through the bear market short-term guys
left at the you know very pico bottom of
of short-term holder supply that's when
the market starts to reverse because all
the short-term speculators are
completely gone um and you know the
people that are buying down there have
strong hands you know because they're
buying when the market looks completely
dead and these are guys with like
long-term conviction um so they kind of
set that floor
as we head back into the the main phase
of the bowl then you start to see the
long-term guys scale out again
short-term guys buy their bags up and so
you see this pattern right um throughout
all bitcoin's history and as you can see
we're we're just starting to reverse the
short-term holder supply uh but you know
another way to look at it is the metric
that uh i've been throwing in for a few
weeks just the long-term holder supply
shock ratio where we kind of reached
that's comparing the long-term and the
short-term guys through a simple ratio
um and so through that you're basically
adjusting adjusting this for supply um
and because you know by definition like
long-term holder supply is going to
trend up you know as there's more supply
and circulation so running the ratio
between short long-term guys kind of
alleviates that like uh
you know
the disadvantage that that you have by
by not like adjusting it for supply but
yeah you're starting to see that reverse
and this is just another way to show
what what we just looked at
but like this is just the zoomed out
version essentially got it when we look
at transaction fees i remember during
the summer one of the things that you
had said was hey you know i got to see
transactions pick up uh because that
would be like my biggest bearish
argument against bitcoin right now with
this is transaction fees uh what are you
seeing here looks like it's ticking up a
little bit
um yeah i mean going back i think i
probably would adjust what i said in the
sense of like
doesn't necessarily mean that uh
the the market itself is bearish because
like low low you know
low demand or or low activity could also
just mean like all the speculators are
gone and it's really just like the smart
money that's left in the market and like
if i could have changed the way or what
i was saying it's just more of like
uh bull market you know
bull market behavior now you know drop
bitcoin's history as has included you
know increasing uh network activity and
so we are starting to see a pickup in
that i mean very slight you see in the
bottom right it's very slight compared
to you know what we've seen in 2017 and
the end of last year leading into the
beginning of this year but i'm watching
to see if we get that continued uptrend
um you know it looks like once we kind
of broke that up trend previously uh
that's that's you know when when the
market started to reverse as well as
like i think you can also kind of use
this as a as kind of a topping signal
where you have that you know huge
blow-off spike and that kind of means
that there's like you know exuberance
and mania and like a lot of you know new
speculators in the market and so the
market's getting a little frothy so um
yeah i'm looking for you know a
sustained uptrend in fees because i
think fees are like a good way to kind
of proxy like block space demand um as
well as like some kind of major you know
spike um you know in the in the months
coming ahead
got it and then we've got the exchange
net position change uh that's in the red
it has been for a while now uh kind of
same thing continuation of what uh what
we previously saw
right right i mean
yeah like we're seeing outflows in the
short term um but also what i just
wanted to show here with the full zoomed
out version is like after march of 2020
i don't want to use the word paradigm
new paradigm but
we've kind of seen this this trend
change and market you know participants
behavior where aside from like
at the end of 2016 leading into 2017
where you saw some pretty heavy like
consistent outflows and there's no
comparable time in
bitcoin's market history to the last
year so where we've just seen sustained
outflows
as well as before the major uh you know
down draw that we had over the summer
we had the the highest day of daily uh
inflows to finance so that's like
another you know you know if we start to
see real
large inflows to exchanges you know day
after day then you know it's probably
time to to be a bit wary but for now
we're still in kind of this sustained
period of outflows and zooming out after
march it seems like we're kind of in
this uh you know
new trend in behavior from from market
participants i mean i think you could
partially just attribute that to like
institutions being in the market driven
by the whole inflation hedge narrative
etc
and you know they're looking to take
custody of their btc in general got it
and then when you think about this uh
very last chart you have around miners
uh it looks like um you know we've got
everything in here from uh uh where the
chinese minor migration or the chinese
mining band occurred all the way back to
it coming back online pretty
aggressively which looks pretty bullish
is that your general read
yeah um you know i think i think um
like hash is definitely correlated to
what the value of the bitcoin network is
because the more hash there is on the
network than the more secure the network
is right
and so you know seeing hash come back
online is great in that sense and then
also just for the decentralization of
bitcoin um you know mining was was
really heavily concentrated in china and
so that was one of the biggest you know
flood narratives that that you know
bitcoin bit excuse me uh that bitcoin
bears would would throw at us right and
they'd say well all the all the miners
are in china and so it's it was pretty
funny honestly over summer that you know
you had all these people that use that
as kind of their one of their main like
bearish uh narratives around bitcoin or
arguments against bitcoin and then you
start to see hash leaving china and
going across the world and
decentralizing itself across the world
and then they're saying you know oh well
all the all the you know hash came off
the network so you know it's just like
you know it's completely contradicting
yourself but um but yeah i mean just
seeing hash come back online is a great
sign because it just shows the
resilience of the bitcoin network right
you know it doesn't matter what
centralized entity you know
bans bitcoin i mean bitcoin hash is
going to find a new home somewhere else
and the network is doesn't have any
centralized point of failure so i mean
yeah i mean it kind of sucked we had you
know hash drawdown and some a bit of a
bit of selling for miners over the
summer but you know the network uh has
come back out even stronger from that um
and so you know bitcoin has a lot of
these events where it's kind of like uh
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
type deal and for long-term investors
you know this was a real bullish event
in my mind um and a reflection of that
hash coming back online aggressively as
you can see in difficulty in the purple
or blue line whatever you want to call
that
we've had eight consecutive positive uh
difficulty adjustments so it's just
another reflection of um how aggressive
hash has come back online
got it joe john what questions do you
guys have it will so we looked at the
chart earlier about long-term holders
selling into strength um and it looks
like it has just started
is there any historical evidence of how
we should think about this like how long
it can go what metrics you should be
looking at et cetera
um
yeah let me can i screenshare
probably i don't think so okay um if
you're able to
go into i think it was the newsletter
two weeks ago
what you'll see is and i'll like talk
through it if you're not able to get it
up um
what you see is that i have the the
long-term molar supply shock ratio
basically plotted out and kind of like
this descending wedge
if you will and so whenever we tag the
upper trend line of that um and for
anybody listening and like if you're by
chance not able to get it up look at uh
week 12's newsletter and then scroll
down it's like the
sixth or seventh chart in the in the
newsletter
when we tag the upper trend line of that
that's usually where we we've kind of
peaked out and because that's showing
that
you have a large amount of supply that's
moving to short-term holders
and then conversely when we tag the
bottom of that trend line
those have actually been really really
good uh bottom signals so it's showing
the bottom uh at the end of 2015
as well as at the bottom of 2018 and
then also during the covet crash we came
back down and tagged the bottom of that
trendline
we hit the bottom of that trend line
about a month ago and so now i'm looking
to reverse back to the upper part of the
trend line in this kind of descending
wedge um and so once we kind of get up
and you know at least in the upper half
of the wedge you know that's when i'll
start to start to kind of look to be
cautious just based off of the behavior
of long-term holders um that's that's
that's you know probably the the best
visual to get like a clear signal on
like you know when when to become
cautious or or you know optimistic about
the market gotcha and i i trust you will
educate us on that when it gets closer
yeah
keep an eye on it all right john what
you got yeah what's up will um
so
what was your takeaway so that's what
did the on-chain metrics say about this
week's volatility we saw go bitcoin go
as high as 69.69 thousand dollars and
then as low as 63 000 was that like i
probably wasn't expected and we know
it's volatile but what would your take
away from all that
yeah i mean i think in the i think in
the short term when you have kind of
these whipsaw moves um a lot of that is
is more so driven by the derivative
stuff
um you know we do insane amounts of uh
volume and you know there's insane
amounts of liquidity in the perpetual
futures market
and so in the short term you know when
those traders get offsides you have
these kind of uh you know flush outs or
reversals um and so that happens often
that's that's part of why bitcoin's so
volatile i think you know in the past
like in like the bitmex glory days
bitcoin is stream it's just like a free
walk trying to liquidate the most
traders uh i still think we have that to
an extent um
and so like that you know i think that
drives a lot of the short-term
volatility but you know when you're
trying to just zoom out and like you
know you don't care about the day-to-day
fluctuations that's where on-chain more
so comes into play um i mean you did see
you did see like some increased spending
as we've talked about from these
long-term guys
as well as you know some slight like
exchange outflows before the event but
uh more than it more than anything i
think a lot of these short-term moves
are just driven by the derivatives
thanks for that
well if you zoom all the way out
we are now into q4 of 2021. what's your
general read we're you know hitting
all-time highs is this kind of what you
would have expected in the beginning of
the year into the spring like q4 of uh
the year after a halving or hitting
all-time highs
yeah i mean i think i know a lot more
about the market than i do like than i
did earlier this year i like i kind of
look back on myself and cringe a little
bit um
but i mean yeah like we've been talking
about how we've kind of been expecting
higher prices into the end of the year
um i think some of these on-chain like
supply specific dynamics that we're
seeing and as well as like like you know
coin dates destroyed and stuff um some
of those things kind of point to
maybe this extending out into the first
few months of next year
um
you know i don't i don't necessarily
look for for timing and we've talked
about this before like i don't look for
timing as to okay the market's going to
end the cycle is going to end in
december because that's when it's
historically ended i'm just looking for
these behaviors so
um
you know i know it's this time time
again but it's like i don't have
specific time or price targets it's more
so like
what are the behaviors that have
you know previously resembled exuberance
or greed in the market and once we see
those i don't know if that happens next
month you know that could all of a
sudden happen within a matter of weeks
or you know it might take several months
for us to get to that point but
historically in terms of how long it's
taken for these dynamics to kind of play
out i mean i think i think there's a
reasonable argument to be made that we
kind of extend out a few months into
next year
but yeah i mean my my conservative kind
of price target for the end of the year
was always i said all-time highs to
about 75k um and you know i still think
that's in the cards um but i mean as far
as the absolute like
pico top i mean we'll have to just you
know keep monitoring these behaviors to
know
for forever what are we doing on a
follower account uh
how are we looking on follower count
uh
i don't know uh let me see well because
i did i did the video with um with willy
woo and plan b and i think that boosted
me up a little bit i'm at 392. oh bro
you got this come on i said 500 cab i've
been saying 500k let's go
will's out of my distance now he was
like you know so he he came by me in the
car
and passed and now he's in a different
state then he waved at
and he said i'll see you later
listen man i appreciate you coming on
here every week uh i know people are
learning i get uh dms all the time
people say listen i'm really learning a
lot so thank you guys for spending the
time to do this if you are not following
will at this point uh you must be new
here which is good we like new people
that's fine uh but highly suggest you go
follow will on uh on twitter and then
also will i think i saw you in the
youtube uh comments this week when dylan
came on you were uh you're in there
dropping all kinds of heat and asking me
to ask him what was the thing on top of
his block clock we'll get in a cube
which yeah you got a cube
no no cubes for me yeah where i i had to
i had to get the bike instead but
pretty good uh purchase i think all
right man
you know what you know i had to you know
had to bust dylan's balls a little bit
yeah listen he appreciated it he i mean
he came on and and uh the first thing i
said to him was he was all kind of
dressed up and everything had his chain
hanging and every and i said hey you
look you look uh spiffy there he goes
yeah you know i gotta have to drip
i was like all right i appreciate them
uh but thank you so much for uh for
coming on and uh we'll do it again next
week i think everyone is uh we're we're
all waiting what is will going to drop
next what metric is he going to create
or or is he going to tell us something's
going to happen before it happens so
keep up the good work and uh you know
this weekend don't do anything that my
brothers and i would do
thanks guys and you know i appreciate
you like you know continuing to push the
on-chain stuff um you know outside of
just like doing these interviews but as
well like on twitter and stuff you know
i think
the further we can push this information
out to new people then it's just you
know it's a it's a additive thing where
you know other people come up with
metrics you create something based off
of their stuff and you know we can kind
of it's it's it's still so early in
terms of uh like you know the the the
metrics we have and like the information
and data we have that you know i think
it it you know it's it's a it's a
win-win for everybody and and we can
kind of all win together at least at
least for now maybe like years down the
road the alpha will get uh we'll get uh
you know
squeezed out a little bit as more people
take off seriously but
no no no we're all in this together my
friend joe john you guys got anything
left
nah man have a good weekend will
appreciate you joining us thanks buddy
all right guys
take it easy